peace be with you welcome to another
exciting episode of the Dene show
subscribe if you're not subscribed
already my next guess baptized at a
young age of 11 accepted this Deen
in 1991 shortly later and then not only
accepted it went on to get a masters in
it get ready to meet mr. Joe actually
shake Joe here on the Dean show we'll be
right back
this is the
this is the Bijou please be with you
assalamualaikum waalaikumsalam o Allah
mr. show Joe Sheikh Joe some people call
you Joey
only my grandmother and my aunt mr. Joe
Shaykh Joe how are you doing I'm great
just Joe is fine my good friend dr.
Brown yes you know him yes he actually
some time ago he had told me he was good
friends with you and that I should get
in contact with you at a hamdullah I
didn't have to look far you actually
ended up in Chicago yeah we just ran
into each other yeah you see you see
Allah makes things happen I'm they're
not all right hamdullah so tell us now I
mentioned when I open to show baptism
yes now that's what you do when you're
from the Christian Catholic religion
well most Christians will will baptized
Catholics baptized at birth
Protestants usually will baptize later
in life because it's a choice you have
to choose to be saved so around the age
of 11 or 12 I was attending a Southern
Baptist Church in the neighborhood that
I lived in in Charleston South Carolina
and I just decided that that was the
thing that I wanted to do Jesus got
baptized and I needed to get baptized
too and so I asked the pastor if he
could do it he said yes and get my
parents permission and I did they
allowed it but they refused to attend
and then he convinced them to at least
you know attend and and then that was
that was it I continued in you know
Vacation Bible School in Sunday school
and all that good stuff as a kid what
does it mean get us more familiar with a
baptism what does it mean you said Jesus
was baptized what is that how do we look
at it from Islamic perspective well so
yeah yeah they said I'm where John the
Baptist was was known for baptizing
people was a symbol of washing away
their sins and for them kind of kind of
like when one of us takes Shahada and so
it was this renewal of life you go into
the water you come out a new person
you're washed of your of your sins so
the concept is there in Islam as the
Prophet Allah saw it sound told some of
his companions allah tala manila
slamming a Juba table who do you not
know that Islam wipes away everything
that
before it so the idea of baptism is the
same except that of course and baptism
they say we baptize you in Jesus name
and it's this dedication to the life of
Jesus so I was inclined to that because
I was the kind of the church-going one
in my family now you said your front
where were you born again I was born in
Detroit Michigan
but you were speaking some other
language I was speaking Arabic yes but
you're not Arab I'm not Arab no what's
going on here that's what everyone
wonders ok because I were trying to
connect by an airport we have a lot of
not yet Muslims out there in there like
ok he's not one of us he's the other
what's he doing speaking he's not
speaking English anglo-saxon he's
speaking Arabic he's an Arabic right
what do you have to say so I learned
Arabic after I accepted Islam at the age
of 15 when I was kind of church going as
a kid off and on going with neighbors
and things like that I always knew that
the Bible had been written in a language
other than what it was revealed in you
know was written in Greek and Latin but
Jesus wasn't Greek and he wasn't Latin
he was he was in Middle Eastern he was
Middle Eastern person he spoke Aramaic
so I wanted to learn Aramaic and then
when I heard about Islam and I became
Muslim and I said what languages of
Quran written and they said it's written
in Arabic the original language it was
real and it blew me away like this is
great I need to learn Arabic so I
started attending Sunday school at the
Islamic Center of Northeast Florida
there in Jacksonville Florida that's
amazing so Destin so first you wanted to
you mentioned something that Jesus was
Middle Eastern so he wasn't many people
in the south for you know some of the
churches they have a man with blue eyes
blond hair that's not the reality well
we don't necessarily know exactly what
he looked like we do have a hadith from
the Prophet Ani syllabus that I'm
explaining that he was a brown skinned
person with curly hair came down to his
his shoulders he had broad shoulders the
description very much fits what we would
consider to be Middle Eastern it was
definitely not Caucasian definitely not
European in origin even there's what
you're saying to the same thing it's in
the Bible mentions it more of a dark
complected person yes yeah ok so then
the other thing is you wanted to just
like someone out of their sincere
earnest
they want to get close to God so now
they want to go back and look at these
scriptures and speak the language to get
closer to God that Jesus would have been
speaking which was Aramaic then you come
to Islam and now the sister language is
Arab is Arabic yeah and you actually go
on to study and you get your master's
degree is this right yes yeah so I
started Sunday school I actually learned
the Arabic language in the United States
to read write and speak I have to give
you know thanks to Allah and then thanks
to one of my first teachers the folklore
Ali Shah was the Imam of the message at
that time kind of gave me the
fundamentals and I was able to run with
it and and then I've been laid around in
1999 I went to Medina did my bachelor's
master's and then I've been you know
working ever since
but hold on what's going on you're
baptized at eleven what are you doing in
Medina at what age is this now
twenty-four twenty-five or what happened
here yeah so you know accepting Aslam at
the age of fifteen finishing up high
school you know to beginning a 10th
grade year people told me you need to go
and learn a slam you need to go to the
Muslim world there was an elderly
brother named Curtis Shabazz me alive
mercy on him you know he sat me down he
was a cancer patient and and he would
drive all the way to the message with
his wife and be so weak he couldn't even
come inside the door so he would direct
the car in the direction of the Qibla
and he would pray in his car so I used
to go on sit with him in his car and he
said look you have to go and learn this
Deen and take it back to the people so I
want you to you know go to overseas so I
started applying for everywhere applied
for as hard a debate you know Medina and
Hum Dil eventually I got into Medina but
I'm talking about someone right now not
yet Muslim you know our brothers in
humanity many of the Christians we never
want to disparage on but they're like
hold on was he not full of the Holy
Ghost if you don't accept Jesus as your
Lord and Savior to die for your sins
you're going to hell far so you dare say
you took a wrong turn now you you maybe
you found the Antichrist I have you
heard some of these things yeah you know
so you know in I believe it's in
Corinthians it says God is not the
author of confusion so face should not
be faith should not be confused
confusing you know the devil cannot
stand on a
and a or foundation got stand on some
people by that I forget this scripture
but I know which one is how about you
know Joe I'm talking about so you know
this idea that it's the Antichrist lamb
is from the Antichrist or the devil
doesn't make sense because Islam
preaches against the Antichrist and
against the devil so it necessarily can
necessarily be from that origin yeah so
what had you leave because you got
baptized right seriously and again why
do people at what age
why do what described a baptism what's
done here you just dipped in the pool
and now you're born again so there's
there's a there's water that's usually
blessed by the pastor of the priest and
then you wear all white garbs much like
a thobe that Mara that Muslims would
marry and that list Muslims would wear
and then you you you go into the baptism
pool and the priest will hold a cloth
over your mouth to protect your nose and
mouth and then hold you by the back of
the head dip you into the water and
he'll be saying you know prayers and
blessings and then bring you back up and
then you say you know you're baptized in
Jesus name and you have started a new
life you know you're not going to be a
perfect person but you've started a new
life
okay our audience wants to know we're
going to find out like what is it that
really at the end you end up went from
baptism and what was it that triggered
you to come over to this way of life
that actually Jesus lived that Moses
lived that Abraham lived we got a lot
more to talk about with mr. Joe Sheikh
Joe here on the Deen show don't go
anywhere
Salaam says love all mankind that's why
we're sharing this message because we
want the best for you and we want the
best for all mankind please subscribe to
the D show follow us on our official
Facebook and Twitter pages in the links
below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show okay so now before I
even get to that you know we're talking
about a subject that many people are
apathetic towards you know religion they
think it's something weird many times
you have a lot of weird things mystical
things associated with it why is this
subject so important
everyone needs a you know everyone needs
a moral code to live by and the thing is
is that human beings are limited in our
comprehension
knowledge so we can't do it alone and if
we recognize that you know tracks on the
beach means someone were what was
walking there waves in the ocean means
you know that there's a current stars in
the sky you know all of these things
should it not tell us that there's
something that made all of this and that
made us and so if we want to know how to
live a moral life to the fullest I'm not
saying that people that don't have faith
can't be moral but if we want to live a
more life to the fullest then we need to
know what the creator of the heavens and
the earth wants from us and and that's
why you know religion is important how
about if someone said can't like science
dictate my moral code science is
empirical science is about as about the
gathering of facts it does it's not
philosophy it's it's it's not it's not
ethics and so it you know you can you
can work within a certain amount of
facts but that doesn't that doesn't
necessarily mean that you're going to
use those facts or that data that's in
front of you correctly we know that the
Quran is a book that's tamper free to
ever prove revealed over span of 23
years it has a challenge you know if you
want to disprove that it's not from God
do this this and that it's based on
reasoning rationale cause people to
think ponder so you know a lot of times
we talk to people of other religions to
talk about how to dream you know this
came over me write a lot of weird things
right is that what happened to you is
that why you came Islam did you see some
something in a dream did some weird
happen to you what was it about Islam
that had you come over so I was uh I was
at home with my older sister and I went
to her room and she had a magazine and
she said here you know read this
magazine do something with your life you
know older sister and in that magazine
there was an article about a girl who
accepted Islam she was a readers column
so she wrote in about the most amazing
thing that happened to her in her life
and and it was becoming a Muslim and so
I read that article and I had never
heard about it Stan before I had heard
about Arabs being from Detroit but I'd
not heard about a stem so piqued my
interest and I went into the
encyclopedia this is pre-internet school
libraries public libraries trying to
find information so I spent that was
when I was 14 years old
I spent the time from 14 to 15 just
looking for information about Islam
do you also did you find that appealing
at the same time that you didn't have to
leave this love for Jesus that we also
in our faith we believe in love Jesus is
one of the mightiest messengers of God
except we don't worship Him as a god
that was actually surprising to me when
I came to the message for the first time
when I went to the Islamic Center of
Northeast Florida was Sunday school time
was talking to people and they were like
you know Jesus and as for as soon as
they said Jesus like hold on am I in the
right place because I was tired about
hearing about the deification of Jesus
so I wanted to make sure that I was you
know I said Jesus worship God I only
want to worship God and he said yeah
don't worry that's that's what Jesus did
and that's what we do so you had so
going back you had a problem with that
you're fit that are what we call it now
the night nature was rejecting this man
worship yeah I mean you read you read
you know all these stories in the Bible
about you know Abraham worship God and
Moses worship God and Isaiah worshiped
God and and then you get to Jesus and he
worshiped God and then there was this
break ok now jesus is the son of God or
Jesus is God or Jesus is Son and God
which didn't make sense to me I remember
going to my pastor as a child in saying
if Jesus is God and Jesus is the Son of
God how can you be your own father and
he just patted me on my back and said
son you just have to have blind faith
and that was actually it was after
baptism that's when I left the church I
started looking for another church to go
to because it just didn't make it didn't
set sit well with me God is not the
author of confusion why am i confused no
answers it's a bottleneck don't think
about it if God endowed me with an
intellect I should be thinking about
what I'm doing that's uh that's a the
antithesis to a myopic way of thinking
now just being restricted to maybe what
your parents are on mm-hmm
just following blindly culture and
society and you went against the odds
because now you went up against society
in the norms and but you were sincerely
earnestly wanting to know the truth and
even though you're going to probably
catch some heat for it did you I did a
little bit yeah yeah I my my parents
were not really sure what it was I was
into you know
my friends at school were kind of
strange but I real good friends are
friends until this day yeah yeah we know
nowadays what are some of the most
common give me one of the most common
questions you might get asked when
someone finds out you're Muslim maybe an
old family friend at a family reunion or
something like that or just someone that
comes in sees your whites as man this
guy's not Arab or something but he's
Muslim
I'm not variable so I'm American born
here right so what would what are they
usually asking I think it's surprising
to a lot of people that they're you know
they've kind of the associate Islam with
being South Asian or Arab and it's
shocking to them and I think I kind of
breaks that that mold of or that false
idol of Islam being foreign know Islam
as justice is is is a religion that has
been here in the United States for
centuries and will be we mentioned blind
faith the pastor was a tone of the
priest tone you just got to have blind
faith yes if someone says well that's
how all religions are we just got a
blind faith what would you attribute
that same thing to Islam what would you
say don't I would say no if you read the
floor on one of the things that that
that really struck me up out of the
Quran is that in every set of verses
you'll find ponder this think about this
contemplate this look in the heavens and
the earth look at the signs that God has
given think so there's this this this
enticement to use your rationale to use
your intellect to to base your faith
upon so but someone says look you just
you missed the boat because now you
don't have someone there to carry your
sins Jesus paid the price and you just
left all that you're going to hell for
that wouldn't were you going to tell me
I would say that the the the problem
with thinking that your cert your your
you know even in Christianity that's a
very popular notion but that's not even
with Christian fathers say many of them
will say that we don't enter paradise
because of our sins or because of Jesus
we enter it because of the grace of God
and as Muslims we believe very similar
that but we the thing is is that we
don't we don't say with certainty that
we're going to heaven are going to help
we said it's the will of God because he
created us he knows
how to judge us so the idea that I'm
somehow forced out of heaven because I
don't have Jesus to save me well who
would save Jesus who would he call on if
he called on someone I could call on
that same person and that's what he did
I get amazed you know that obviously the
Lord's Prayer yes would you say it's so
similar to the l-fatiha
I would yeah you know a call I just call
out how our Father who art in heaven if
you just say our creator or I'm our Lord
our Lord who art in heaven how does the
Resco hallowed be 9ne them come thy will
thy will be done
yes was he doing Islam and was he a
Muslim in Jesus yes of course how when
you first when you found that out before
we go to break how someone said how is
that that's impossible how is he a
Muslim doing Islam well well when you
when you when you submit to God you're a
Muslim so everything that submits to God
is what is Muslim because Muslim means
the one who submits their will in their
life to God
beautiful exciting I'm excited with mr.
Joe no shake Joe here in the Deen show
we'll be right back with more don't go
anywhere
Salaam says love all mankind that's why
we're sharing this message because we
want the best for you and we want the
best for all mankind please subscribe to
the D show follow us on our official
Facebook and Twitter pages in the links
below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the Deen show now many of us who
live this life we see that things just
kind of get played out jaded real
quickly you know you just wake up it's
kind of a what's that movie gophers day
I'm here it was it I'm saying way back
in the day was like he just keep
repeating the same thing oh yeah oh the
Bill Murray movie yeah yeah and many
people just keep doing the same thing
from Monday - yeah because I monotonous
but monotonous you know but here I want
to share one one verse from the verbatim
Word of God the Quran and I want you
since I we have an opportunity to be
with someone who studied in the Islamic
University to share your thoughts with
us because I often this is one of my
favorite verses from the car
we're the creators saying in chapter 57
verse 20 know that the life of this
world is but play an amusement and
diversion adornment and boasting to one
another and competition an increase of
wealth and children like the example of
rain whose resulting plant growth
pleases the tillers then it dries and
you see it turn yellow then it become
scattered to breathe and in the
hereafter is a severe punishment and
forgiveness from Allah and approval and
what is the worldly life except the
enjoyment of delusion I mean I just you
know coming back also from those days
where you just live for this dunya what
this is so powerful what how would you
summarize this his first first thing
that comes to mind when I hear this
verse is the cyclical nature of life you
can be in a cycle that you think is
never-ending and I know that I've been
there in life where I didn't really know
what the next day was going to be what
the next month was going to be and and
what I could expect out of life you get
to the point where you think well am I
gonna live to thirty am I gonna live to
40 I don't know what's going to happen
after that
whereas the example that's given in the
verse is that what you're experiencing
right now will end and you have to be
prepared for it so don't be deluded into
thinking that this life is going to be
forever and that there's nothing after
it you have to be responsible for your
own deeds you have to have
accountability for yourself and you will
be accounted for one day
and when you realize that you realize
that in reality you know this life is
not about the material that you have but
it's about the meanings that you leave
behind usually when we hear these
stories it's really inspirational and
I've hummed Allah thank god I've
interviewed so many people that have
come over to this way of light because
it's it's it's a rational thinking man's
decision that you make you don't just
Mason did you did you just make this
base off emotion or did you really I
mean using I took a I took a year I mean
a reading off and on Kim you know I said
to myself well Islam seems like it came
after Christianity maybe something else
came after Islam I started researching
Shintoism and jainism sikhism and all of
the Eastern religions that I had never
been exposed to and every time I
contrasted and compared as time
on top whether it was justice whether it
was beauty whether it was devotion
whether it was prayer whether duty to
parent Islam always came up on top and
that's what motivated me to become a
Muslim it wasn't the thing of saying the
certainty of just saying yeah I'm saved
in Jesus's name and then going out and
just wiling out the entire week right
but it was I have to be a responsible
person in myself I have to be regimen I
have to be accountable for myself and
when I'm accountable for myself and
you're accountable for yourself then
even just from a secular standpoint
society is better off so you know faith
adds to society in the sense that it
gives every person a regimen and a
personal responsibility so that they can
be a contributing member to the general
welfare of society and they'll get their
reward in the next life as well we
mentioned I asked you about Jesus being
a Muslim he obviously never heard this
word Christian if you brought him back
today you know he'd be like what are you
talking about I was one who submitted to
love that that's ie a Muslim just like
Moses Avery they were almost some
Abraham same thing and they were doing
Islam Islam you said we could say that
this is also the lifestyle they were
living yeah like from the bigoted we can
put it all together from the very
beginning the first man Adam until the
last final mission from Muhammad with
all the prophets in between of course
how can we do that how can we do that
yeah because most people when they look
at Hinduism they say okay this came
before Islam they think Christianity but
when I tell people look Islam when you
define it submission to the will of God
it was the first original religion well
it's the theory of history okay so we
don't have an you know in Islamic
thought the theory of history is that
everything started off with guidance
from God and then diverged from there
whereas in other theories of history
they say well everyone was searching for
the truth and they heard they all have
variant origins then we say no the
origin was one God has always sent
guidance to people and that's why you'll
find people that say for example from
the Indian subcontinent and other parts
of the world let's say we have these
indications of the oneness of God and
their being someone sent very early on
in our religious scriptures and then it
was you know people that came after that
priests and pundits and Sadducees and
all these that changed these type of
things or added or subtracted
and that's why you have the left final
Prophet Muhammad because he came to - -
as a criterion for what had come before
to say this was right from it this was
wrong from it and now here the general
principles that you live by until the
day of judgement tell us now you
obviously you clot you are climbing and
you're still climbing the spiritual
ladder meaning that you're seeking
knowledge this Deen requires work and
effort how important is it for many of
the people who take it for granted they
don't like to you know stay at their job
position in school at a certain level
that you just want to keep climbing but
you see like Muslims today they don't
see the value of seeking knowledge and
climbing that spiritual ladder right you
know it's some if you give a great
example many times we we endeavor for
the best in our in our line of work we
endeavor for the best in our personal
enjoyment but when it comes to our faith
then we wondered why we wonder why we're
depressed we wonder why we're worried
but if we if we if we do endeavor to be
the best even as a person of faith and
he's even in worshipping God then we can
start to free ourselves from those
negative emotions not rid ourselves and
that's completely different thing two
pieces of advice one for now the Muslim
the one who's chosen constantly and
again Islam is not something inherited
you got to make that consciousness
definitely many have have still gone
through the rituals maybe their family
you know just brought them up but they
still there they're confused many are
going towards this whole new trend that
these trends atheism new atheism right
so the Muslim was tuned in and he's like
he likes what you had to say he's
impressed he's like what this guy you
know he's American born here was
Christian baptized went to study
overseas and got his master's degree
he's lost he's confused what advice
would you give him I would say that no
one can no one can solve the problem or
the dilemma that you have in your mind
you have to think what you're dedicated
to the problem is with many Muslims that
take their faith for granted there many
times taking it as a part and parcel of
their ethnic identity their cultural
identity just something that they grew
up with and you have to say is if this
is part of me I should understand it if
I claim to be an engineer I should know
engineering if I claim to be a most
I should know Aslam and last piece of
advice for the not-yet Muslim because
everyone has the potential to submit to
the will of God that's all that Islam is
something she said will of God but he
keeps seeing all these crazy things that
the media showing them he's scared
right and you know what it makes sense
the pure monotheism and all the other
things what we're saying but again all
of these negative stereotypes that he's
got his mind she's got in her mind what
would you say to me I would say
remain open to the truth do don't don't
take things at face value do your own
research think about it yourself you're
an individual you have your own mind and
be open-minded to learning about things
and to becoming a better person and when
you do that with this with sincerity
then God will guide you we're out of
time but tell us we got some more time a
about your book and yeah so this is a
simple as a cat guide it's a book that I
wrote for you know one of the five
pillars of Islam is a cat many Muslims
are mystified by it because as to do
with money and how do you calculate it
either you find a pamphlet in the
message it'd that isn't descriptive
enough or you've got a voluminous work
by a scholar that's two three volumes
you have time to read so I made this
simple book with worksheets that people
can go through step by step understand
how they can fulfill their duty to their
fellow man and giving back to the
communities that they live in besides
selling in sending salams to to
everybody out there the piece you want
to send peace to our brother who uh dr.
Lawrence Brown I just see a middle one I
haven't seen him in a long time so yes
nobody come down so like we start Aquila
we have a peace peace be with you Salaam
Lee thank you so much thank you and that
was mr. Joe Shaikh Joe here on the Dean
show you can check him up at his web
site get his book and also 100 percent
compliance for your wills and when we
say Sharia man this is the law that
Moses brain this is the law that all the
messages of God call people to purpose
of life while you're here why you've
been created you want to know if you
just popped up on the moon what you were
doing there so what are you doing on
this earth just to attain a lot of
wealth and money and then what you'd I
just heard a story you know a true story
a man a million twenty million dollars
in front of the fountain he died he left
all you think he took any of that money
whether he took he left it all behind so
what are you preparing for your trip
that trip that we're going to take after
we leave this life everything's become a
past tense been there done that but see
the intellectual person he's not my Opik
see he's not narrow-minded he's thinking
ultimately of what comes for infinity
and that's the next life that all of
these messengers they call people to
think about to reflect over to be
accountable for what they're going to do
in this life and to attain the next life
by obeying the commands of God by being
good doing good and it's all built on
that pure monotheism that Jesus was upon
that Moses was upon the Abraham and all
the other messages including the last
and final messenger sent to mankind who
I'll end with this story this is diseth
entik hadith where he described him as
as a beautiful brick house beautiful man
a beautiful house that everybody was
just going around and an adoring they
said but look look there's just a little
piece of a brick missing here what's
what's with that he said that's what I
represent
he was the finality finishing the
completion of this house this
messengership and he's the last and
final messenger sent to mankind problem
having peace be upon him get to know him
get to know Islam get to know the truth
call us